les organisateurs l'ont baptisé la
marche du million ils étaient peut-être
moins mais ils sont venus en masse
défendre la réforme judiciaire souhaitée
par le gouvernement
c'est l'identité même du pays qui est en
jeu pour Benjamin Philippe on peut pas
vivre comme des Juifs on peut garder
une paix notre pays avec notre reine des
DJ juives
pour beaucoup ici c'est la Cour suprême
qui est dans la ligne de mire jamais
elle ne devrait pouvoir renverser des
décisions du gouvernement qu'ils ont élu
au nom du droit
à gauche israélienne est une menace pour
Israël croit cet homme
dont un groupe problème parce qu'ils
sont une minorité au pays et ils
demandent à la Cour suprême de faire fit
de la démocratie dit-il
on en veut à la Cour suprême d'avoir
renversé des décisions du gouvernement
comme celle de permettre l'établissement
de certaines colonies puisque la loi
israélienne les avait déjà déclarés
comme étant illégal
où est la démocratie où est-elle devant
cet homme on comprend qu'il faut des
équilibres mais aujourd'hui il n'y a que
le système juridique il court sont
équivalentes à la dictature
les manifestations monstres des quatre
derniers mois qui s'opposent à toute
tentative de limiter les pouvoirs de la
Cour suprême ont forcé banyamine
Netanyahou à mettre la réforme
judiciaire sur pause pour négocier avec
le position
mais toute recherche de compromis et
futile croate Évelyne Cohen tu sais
c'est comme brouiller de l'eau
qu'est-ce
qu'elle dit cette réforme va c'est à
dire aujourd'hui on est jeudi dimanche
en une heure la réforme elle passe
en faveur de la réforme judiciaire lui
n'y croit plus penyamin Netanyahu a
compris que les divisions étaient trop
vives que les risques pour le pays
étaient trop grands
et d'une polarisation jusqu'au point où
on ne pourrait plus se remettre de ce
fosser l'on découragé dit-il du Premier
ministre qu'il connaît depuis
l'adolescence
les députés des membres du cabinet de
Benyamine Netanyahu était présent ce
soir pour s'adresser à la foule dans
certains des ministres les plus à droite
de son gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
itemar benville le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui a été condamné pour
incitation aux racistes dans le passé et
à militer pour la déportation des arabes
a été accueilli en héros par la foule
il ne faut pas s'écraser il ne faut pas
succomber à la pression leur a-t-il dit
il ne faut pas céder aux menaces des
médias il faut suivre notre vérité et
nos décisions c'est la droite qui dirige
les groupes qui eux s'opposent à la
réforme judiciaire promettent une
riposte d'envergure ce samedi partout au
pays pour une 17e semaine consécutive
ils envahiront les rues pour dénoncer ce
qu'il considère comme le danger imminent
d'une dictature mais cyanique ici
marie-eveda Radio-Canada Jérusalem